Hello.
Pour commencer je citerai
la comédie musicale Roméo et Juliette:
«Aimer c'est ce qu'il y a de plus beau".
C'est de la merde.
C'est copié sur Notre Dame de Paris.
Ils ont juste remplacé Quasimodo par Roméo.
*Siffle*
Super.
Aujourd'hui je reçois Christian.
Christian est l'homme le plus hater du monde.
Mais vous essayez de vous en sortir.
TG.
Pardon?
TG!
Ça veut dire «Ta gueule» en commentaire!
Pardon.
Excusez moi j'essaye de m'en sortir.
Alors pour ceux qui ne savent pas, un hater c'est quoi?
C'est quelqu'un qui derrière son ordinateur,
confond un peu cynisme et trait d'esprit.
Et qui va critiquer un peu...
FDP.
Pardon?
On critique que dalle!
On dit juste tout haut
ce que tout le monde pense tout bas.
Espèce de vieille merde, de gros conn-
Oh pardon.
Vieux réflexe.
C'est pas très grave.
Comment on devient hater Christian?
Une connerie.
Soirée foot avec les potes,
on commande des pizzas.
Le livreur arrive.
À l'heure.
Les pizzas étaient délicieuses
et je décide de mettre cinq étoiles.
Et là mon doigt rippe
et j'ai mis qu'une seul étoile.
Qu'est ce qui se passe là?
J'ai aimé ça putain.
J'ai adoré.
Là vous dites:
« C'est l'engrenage».
C'est à dire que...
Juste je vous coupe.
Excusez moi mais la chemise
elle est vraiment dégueulasse.
Ya pas idée de mettre
des chemises de merde comme ça.
T'as pas envie de te respecter!
Pardon, désolé.
Mais bon c'est vrai qu'elle
est quand même pas terrible.
Pouce rouge.
Là vous dites: «C'est l'engrenage».
C'est à dire que vous allez
de plus en plus sur les sites internet
pour laisser des mauvais commentaires,
des pouces rouges à tout va.
Qu'est ce qu'il se passe?
Vous basculez un jour de décembre 2014.
Ouais c'est ça. En fait...
En fait, je vais sur une vidéo.
C'était le nouveau clip à la mode qui sortait.
Et là je vois 750 484 vues.
Zéro pouces rouges.
Et là ça a été plus fort que moi quoi.
*Claque sur la cuisse*
Pouce rouge.
On vous appelle « The Red Finger» depuis.
C'est ça oui.
Une mitraillette à pouces rouges.
*Imites son de mitraillette avec sa bouche*
Je peux en mettre 1 million par jour.
En fait vous êtes jaloux c'est ça?
Pardon?
Ben je dis: vous êtes jaloux.
Vas-y répète le!
Je dis: vous êtes jaloux.
*tonalité de touches de portable*
Vous faites quoi là Christian?
Ben le «jaloux»
t'as laissé une bonne critique de merde
sur ta photo de profil Facebook.
Connard!
Pardon.
Non mais c'est ridicule,
je suis en face de vous.
Ben non c'est plus facile derrière un portable.
En plus vous utilisez un pseudo.
C'est à dire que c'est même pas votre vrai nom.
Oui, «bogossdu86».
Ben c'est totalement mensonger.
Bah oui moi je suis du 92.
Mais vous disiez vouloir vous en sortir.
Qu'est ce que vous faites pour ça?
Ben j'essaye d'aller voir des vidéos
et de mettre des commentaires plutôt positifs quoi,
mais c'est difficile.
Genre «J'adore»,
«Beau travail»,
«Je respecte».
Ouais non peut-être pas ça.
Mais du style :
«Ouais sympa, peut mieux faire»,
«J'ai souri mais pas rie».
Mouais c'est essayé de donner un petit peu de...
Pourquoi vous n'avez pas été
capable de mettre un seul pouce vert?
Mais arrête avec tes pouces verts connard là!
C'est quoi ça?
«Pouce vert, pouce vert, pouce vert».
C'est quoi? T'es écolo?
Espèce de fils de pu- Oh!
Je me suis arrêté au bon moment.
Pardon.
Ben alors.
J'ai une surprise pour vous voilà.
Vous allez mettre votre premier pouce vert,
en direct pour nous, sur une vidéo.
*son de la vidéo*
Je l'ai déjà vu cette vidéo.
Je la trouve pas super marrante.
Ouais bon.
C'est... c'est pas le meilleur exemple.
Il joue mal, c'est pas très drôle.
C'est le gros qui joue mal.
Où ça?
Je vois pas de gros sur la vidéo.
À la semaine prochaine.
C'est la fin de cette émission.
Merci de nous avoir suivi...
Bonsoir!
First!
Ta gueule!
Pardon.
*raclement de gorge*